mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
logic and intelligence tests like this
one often spread across social media
but this particular problem is based on
a well-defined mathematics puzzle
suppose we have a binary operation on
real numbers x and y
such that x combines with y to be a
times x plus b times y plus c for
constants a b and c you are given that 3
and 5 combine to be 16
and 4 and 7 combine to be 30.
what do 1 and 1 combine to be
this problem is from the online
mathematics challenge of 2020.
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
when you're ready keep watching to learn
how to solve this problem
[Music]
we know what x and y combine to be and
we have the 3 and 5 combined to be 16.
therefore we have 3a plus 5b plus c is
equal to 16.
since 4 and 7 combine to be 30 we have
4a plus 7b plus c is equal to 30.
we want to figure out the value of one
and one
which is the value of a plus b plus c
let's focus on these two equations
to get started a standard technique in
these types of problems is to manipulate
the two equations so let's subtract the
second equation from the first
we'll cancel out the c terms and we get
a plus 2b is equal to 14.
now let's take these same two equations
and we'll add them together
we get 7a plus 12b plus 2c is equal to
46.
let's work with these two resultant
equations
let's multiply the second equation by
negative five
we'll get negative five a minus ten b is
equal to negative seventy
we will then add this equation to the
first equation
we then get two a plus two 2b plus 2c is
equal to negative 24.
now all we have to do is divide this
equation by 2 and we get a plus b plus c
is equal to negative 12 and a plus b
plus c is exactly what 1 and 1 combine
to be therefore our answer is negative
12.
thanks for joining me in today's mental
workout see you soon as we continue to
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]